you think you know these people because
of the sitcom what if i told you the
sitcom was just dinner conversation and
this was like the diary of that story
you know we're having a great time out
here filming it's just another day
filming and building just
[Music]
hey i'm just another day trying to be
okay playing with my dupe jumbo ray what
[Music]
i think the original fresh prince the
show has such
a a superpower in bridging gaps
um we were able to really find humanity
between
so many different types of people and
races and creeds and colors i think that
what this
new iteration will be able to do in the
same way that we never shied away from
difficult subjects i just think it's
needed and it will be truly powerful in
these current times
action java action really go there
really go there it's a beautiful story
about a boy turning into a man a fish
out of water a coming-of-age story
something that's so recognizable to so
many other people to so many young
people is going to be great you're going
to be seeing so many themes that are
recognizable to us as a community and as
a people
this is where you can really pull back
the pages and be like we didn't know who
carlton was wait a minute maybe we were
wrong about carlton maybe there was more
to hillary that then we gave her credit
for i mean how am i going to be a star
if i do the same thing as everybody else
i think it's also great to tell black
stories from black people's lives and
their experiences and it doesn't have to
feel like you're selling out you know
hey
welcome to beautiful la we want to see
projects that represent and reflect the
world outside our window do that on this
show it's an accurate representation of
of of us and um all different spectrum
different sides different colors there's
so much in there about elevating our
culture showing how diverse nuanced we
are we are not all the same and i think
through this whole series you will see
that in the interactions of characters
the story lines the clothes you know the
themes as well as the music it's gonna
be so great to see this family just
thrive and fall apart and come back
together on screen
hey guys let's go back to one let's go
back to one
the cast is amazing their talent is
amazing these stories are compelling
we're grounding it all in a world that
everyone uh who we'll be watching can
recognize and it's not something distant
anymore mama
say something please well abel has real
good mom energy
and uh it's just so easy to play off of
you know what i mean
yeah and uh so much so that sometimes i
want to take the back of his hand and
give him a good
guys hold that backslash right there
hold that look
why should people watch bel air just
watch it because it's bel air
yo it's good as [ __ ] uh like i ain't
even gonna front it's a great [ __ ]
show
honestly an amazing show trust us like
we wouldn't do this if it wasn't gonna
come correct
[Music]